causeur de presse donné récemment par le
moteur de la république il a été
confirmé l'origine halliche de
l'assaillant et de sa famille ils sont
revenus en france en 2008 lui demander
asile politique
leurs collègues du ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est quoi rester au contact jusqu'à
présent et je crois que je t'attaque
soit laquelle ils doivent à venir et ce
matin plusieurs centaines de parents
d'élèves et de riverains se sont rendus
spontanément devant le collège de bois
donne à conflans certains ont brandi des
pancartes avec les une du magazine
satirique charlie hebdo mais pas celle
des caricatures du prophète qui ont
conduit à la décapitation de
l'enseignant l'émotion aussi des caisses
mais aussi des questions pourquoi ce
professeur n'at-il pas été protégé ou
signalé par sa hiérarchie il avait en
effet fait l'objet de vives critiques de
la part de certains parents d'élèves
pour avoir montré ses caricatures il se
savait menacé le père d'une jeune fille
de 13 ans absente pourtant ce jour là
avait même porté plainte et diffusé une
vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux
pierre pissavy yvernault
réveil sous le choc ce samedi matin pour
les habitants de
conflans-sainte-honorine dans le
département des yvelines
la veille un professeur d'histoire âgé
de 47 ans a été froidement décapités ont
pleine rue pour les conflanais et les
anciens élèves du collège
la situation semble tout simplement
irréel comme comme beaucoup d'entre nous
nous sommes choqués par l'événement qui
vient de se passer
donc c'est un événement qui est
complètement inattendu et et ça se passe
à côté de chez nous donc on est on est
vraiment concerné par parce qu'il va se
passer sous le choc ce parce que nous
c'est un ancien professeur on est au
lycée maintenant mais c'est enfin
c'était choquant ça paraît irréel en
fait de se dire que il ya un professeur
qui est mort parce qu'il faisait son
métier
nous on a eu ce cours là et ça s'est
très très bien passé et se dire que
vaille les morts parce qu'ils à son
métier et en plus d'une façon horrible
et inciter sushi shop très très choquant
un professeur tué pour avoir montré le 5
octobre dernier des caricatures du
prophète mahomet à ses élèves de 4e dans
cette ville paisible de la banlieue
parisienne
l'heure est au recueillement un soutien
psychologique a été mise en place au
collège
le maire de conflans-sainte-honorine lui
tente de rassurer ses administrés
il ya aujourd'hui au sein du collège le
bois donne une permanence de soutien
psychologique a été mise en place qui
est destiné aux parents d'élèves
destiné aux enseignants et surtout
destiné en premier aux élèves j'étais il
ya encore deux semaines pour conseil de
sécurité de prévention de la délinquance
et le constat partagé par la préfecture
par la police nationale par la police
municipale et par les habitants par les
associations de prévention était le même
nous sommes ici à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans une ville
où il fait bon vivre
alors je dois dire aujourd'hui à mes
habitants que nous nous relèverons une
émotion aussi partagé par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et jean michel
blanc coeur rend hommage au professeur
et à sa famille
comme le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine il évoque un
besoin d'unité face à ce nouvel attentat
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
pris la parole ce matin jean michel
blanquer requis souhaite je cite un
recadrage pédagogique fort puissant et
stricte dès la rentrée le 2 novembre
après les vacances de la toussaint alors
que l'opposition réclame des actes et
non plus des paroles le ministre précise
que tous les élèves devront observer une
minute de silence ce qui s'est passé est
inqualifiable
ça n'a pas de nom et ça doit être
combattu ce qui s'est passé a des
racines ses racines c'est la haine et
c'est la haine de la république il ya
clairement les ennemis de la république
contre la république et donc contre
l'école parce que l'école c'est la
colonne vertébrale de la république
c'est pourquoi notre réaction doit être
à la hauteur
d'abord la sérénité ensuite l'unité dès
ce matin j'ai reçu les organisations
syndicales de l'éducation nationale pour
que cette unité et cette sérénité se
manifeste je veux leur rendre hommage
car le climat de cette réunion a été à
la hauteur des enjeux nous convergeons à
la fois sur l'analyse et sur l'attitude
et des méthodes que nous devons avoir
pour les tons de futures et voyez à
présent les réactions de jean paul
huchon si un maire socialiste de
conflans sainte honorine face à notre
éditorialiste politique alexis poulain
totalement fou ce qui s'est passé un
enseignant fait son travail qu'il
apporte des éléments de réflexion sur
la liberté de pensée et les valeurs
républicaines
il est décapité ce qui est terrible et
il est également victime d'une folie
absolue qui vient de se passer
donc tu d'autant plus frappés que ce
collège jolie de bure et commerces de
conflent à l'époque et qu'il est il
était réputé comme un bond collage dans
lequel on travaillait bien dans un
quartier où il n'y avait aucun problème
de sécurité ni de violence voilà que la
sentence est tombée par un fou du jihad
un jeune tchétchène qui a décidé lui de
faire justice lui même parce que pour
lui les lois qui sont les siennes les
lois de sa foi djihadistes valent bien
mieux et dépasse la loi de la république
alors non c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne on attend maintenant au delà
du discours d' emmanuel macron et des
gestes du ministre de l'intérieur des
lois ferme des prises de décisions
fermes pour que cesse enfin
c'est de cette poussée de l'intérieur
que certains appellent séparatisme où
certains voudraient que la croyance
unique vaut moral et loi ce n'est pas le
cas la république est laïque la
république permet à chacun de croire ce
qu'elle veut et à chacun de dire ce
qu'il veut 20 millions de francs s'est
assignée à résidence de 21h à 6h du
matin pendant au moins quatre semaines
le couvre-feu en ile de france et dans
huit métropoles est entrée en vigueur la
nuit dernière dernière soirée donc hier
jusqu'à minuit pour être aux terrasses
des cafés ou des restaurants à paris
lyon marseille lille montpellier
toulouse saint-etienne rouen et grenoble
et douze mille policiers et gendarmes
mobilisés pour faire respecter cette
mesure
voyez ce qu'en dit rocco contento il est
secrétaire départemental paris unité sgp
police
nous sommes une nouvelle fois mis à
contribution pour la bonne application
du couvre feu
je vous rappelle que nous avons été mis
à contribution pour faire appliquer le
confinement
ensuite pour accompagner le
déconfinement et là nous avons mission
de faire respecter le couvre feu
le statut travailleurs de nuit c'est
autre chose le ministre a fait une
annonce mais les collègues deux jours
qui travaillent la nuit de bénéficieront
pas du statut travailleurs de nuit parce
que je vous rappelle qu'il faut
effectuer un certain nombre d'heures
dans l'année pour bénéficier de ce
statut
donc si vous voulez ça râle dans la nuit
dans la maison police on fera quand même
la mission parce que toute somme des
policiers républicains
mais voilà il faut pas nous en demander
trop non plus puisque le policier où est
mis à contribution en ce moment et
depuis un certain temps pour tout et
n'importe quoi
une marche des sans papiers aujourd'hui
dans la capitale française une
manifestation qui a débuté place de la
république et des protestataires qui
réclament la régularisation des sans
papiers la fermeture des centres de
rétention administratif ainsi qu'un
logement pour les étrangers un mouvement
qui intervient dans le prolongement
d'une mars lancé le 19 septembre dernier
à marseille et dans d'autres métropoles
de l'hexagone et coûté organisé une
marche des sans papiers il marche
nationale des sans-papiers depuis
le 19 septembre et ça a démarré entre
marseille et montpellier
nous avons démarré montpellier et
marseille parce que nous avons relevé
nos camarades de marseille et
montpellier nous l'est les collectifs de
paris pour qu'on nous une convergence
ensemble et marcher ensemble pour
arriver aujourd'hui à paris nous avons
des objectifs des revendications à
athènes
c'est la fermeture des centres de
rétention administratif ya la
régularisation sans conditions de toutes
et tous les sans papiers le logement
décentes pour toutes et tous et la
liberté de circulation et d'installation
cela il va avec nos revendications
ça fait depuis 2004 parce que je suis là
et j'ai eu des papiers j'ai les ai
perdus et actuellement je suis toujours
je suis rendement des policiers près de
trois semaines que les affrontements ont
lieu dans le haut-karabakh un cessez le
feu conclu la semaine dernière entre
arménien et azéri cessez le feu qui ne
tient pas puisque il est violet presque
quotidiennement à part ce n'était pas ma
carte là la capitale de cette région
contestée bombardé à plusieurs reprises
la ville azéri de ganja également été
prises pour cible voyez les précisions
de grégoire doucet le conflit s'enlise
et les civils en pâtissent ici à gandja
des azerbaïdjanais pleurent leurs
proches victimes collatérales des
combats des scènes que connaît également
depuis plusieurs semaines stepanakert
capitale du haut karabagh de nombreux
habitants se réfugient dans les sous
sols les forces des deux camps se
rendent coup pour coup et continuent de
se rejeter mutuellement la
responsabilité des affrontements
les dirigeants arméniens sont en train
de commettre un crime de guerre
tirer sur des civils et lançaient des
roquettes est un crime de guerre
le budget de mars
nous nous vengerons sur le champ de
bataille et nous vengerons nos martyrs
et nos innocents nous n'avons jamais
combattu et nous ne nous battrons jamais
contre des civils pour erevan la
responsabilité principale de la guerre
un combat la turquie bien sûr il y a des
preuves directes que les combattants
terroristes de syrie lutte contre le
haut karabagh les preuves vidéos ont
déjà été publiées sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans les médias et maintenant
il est évident que la turquie est le
principal commanditaire de cette guerre
pour les civils la peur fait désormais
partie du quotidien
ce sont de vrais barbares qui peut
lancer des roquettes sur des gens qui
dorment la nuit
je pense que c'est l'élimination non
seulement du peuple azerbaïdjanais
mais aussi des russes et des
azerbaïdjanais qui vivent ici
les géorgiens et les tatars vivent
également ici et il est temps de mettre
fin à ce génocide
nous avons tous fait appel au président
nous sommes prêts pour la guerre chaque
fois que le commandant suprême en chef
le dit personne ne peut nous faire peur
comme ça
de tels évènements nous rendre encore
plus déterminés il y a eu une alarme
pendant toute la nuit et nous ne
pouvions pas dormir on nous bombarde et
mais à vrai dire nous sommes déjà
habitués à tout cela
je suis sorti ce matin et j'ai pu nous
routes endommagées près d'un kiosque les
vitres brisées c'est très effrayant
malgré des appels répétés à une
cessation réel des hostilités est la
communauté internationale restent pour
l'instant impuissante face à cette
escalade des tensions
le premier anniversaire de la révolution
au liban marquée aujourd'hui par des
manifestations de 17 octobre dernier le
pays a été confronté à un mouvement de
contestation sans précédent contre la
corruption des élites politiques
mais depuis il ya eu la crise le virus
et le drame du port de beyrouth et la
vie des libanais en a été profondément
bouleversé
mona hamoud un an après la révolution du
cèdre commencé le 17 octobre 2019
l'heure est au bilan
malheureusement pour le liban le constat
est triste voire très amer avec de
funestes événements
ce mouvement populaire a permis à une
jeunesse pleine d'espoir de dénoncer la
corruption d'un système politique ainsi
que ces dérives sectaires
nous étions sur place dès le début de
cette vague de protestation inédite et
les manifestations n'avaient rien de
commun fait dj en plein air stands de
nourriture mais aussi groupes de parole
entre libanais venus des quatre coins du
pays pour parler économie société et
politique des liens avaient été tissés
et les barrières brisé de tripoli elle a
bâti et chiites sunnites druzes ou
encore maronite se retrouvaient pour
finalement constater qu'ils vivaient
tous les mêmes galères au quotidien et
qui n'était pas si différents les bauges
dans nouveaux lits vont se dessiner peu
à peu avec une génération qui voulaient
se réapproprier l'espace public dans un
pays où 40% de la population est au
chômage
les jeunes avaient l'occasion d'exprimer
leur frustration et surtout d'envisager
la naissance d'un système laïque et
égalitaire
je rêve d'un liban où la souveraineté du
citoyen c'est la priorité je rêve d'un
liban civile jardin liban où la
diversité c'est un autre point fort pas
notre point faible
allez donc il n'est pas esclave aux
agendas politiques d'autres pays
cette révolution a entraîné la démission
de trois premiers ministres au total en
l'espace d'un an
alors que le liban lui continué sa
descente aux enfers
petit à petit les libanais ont vite
compris que les dirigeants ne comptait
pas céder leur place et la révolution a
changé de visage
les manifestations qui était familiale
voire festifs sont devenus plus
violentes
l'armée libanaise a eu recours à un
usage excessif de la force
mutilant même de nombreux manifestants
le facteur malchance fut aussi de la
partie la pandémie de kobe 19 et le
confinement ou paralyser le mouvement
populaire et surtout l'effroyable drame
qui a eu lieu le 4 août 2020 alors que
le pays est au bord du gouffre criblé de
dettes sans perspectives politiques et
sociales une double explosion au port de
beyrouth vient ôter le peu d'espoir qui
restait à une population épuisée et
appauvrie plus de 200 personnes perdent
la vie
6500 sont blessées et 300 mille paires
de leur maison une fois encore la
corruption de la classe politique est
pointé du doigt
que faisait plus de deux mille sept cent
cinquante tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
dans un entrepôt en plein centre-ville
ap réponse de l'exécutif et aucun
sursaut de la classe politique n'aura
lieu malgré la gravité de la situation
aujourd'hui le liban qu'on appelait la
suisse du moyen orient est un pays en
chute libre et des milliers de libanais
quittent le pays plus de 50 % de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
un niveau de crise jamais atteint même
pendant la guerre civile qui a ravagé le
territoire entre 1975 et 1990 plusieurs
facteurs expliquent aussi pourquoi la
révolution n'a pas pris le tournant
attendu il ne faut pas sous-estimer la
solidité du système politico
communautaire ces partis ont la chance
d'être soutenue par une base
d'irréductibles l'absence de leaders
capables de faire l'unanimité est
également un facteur important puisque
aucune figure populaire n'a pu faire
trembler les dirigeants politiques
actuels ce qui les conforte dans leur
influence alors même si la révolution a
été noyé par ces péripéties malheureuse
la colère est toujours aussi forte
la flamme de la révolte est encore
présente et les libres
mais combien l'exploiter pour apporter
un second souffle à la révolution du
cèdre et voyez ce qu'en dit fois de ce
mot col il est président du
rassemblement des dirigeants et il est
également chef d'entreprise libanais il
préconise des sanctions contre ceux qui
tiennent le pouvoir au liban
actuellement et une aide extérieure
juste après 7 17 octobre on a eu quand
même trois grands événements qu'il faut
rappeler on a eu finalement le 7 mars
2020 l'annoncé officielle du défaut
libanais quand le gouvernement al ahmar
publier ses bons du trésor en euros par
la suite évidemment on a eu comme tous
les pays du monde le coc vide et il faut
pas oublier la dramatique l'apocalypse
la tragédie l'explosion du 4 août
finalement qui a détruit la capitale
libanaise complètement et finalement ou
quitter le coup de grâce jeudi à ce pays
malheureusement qu'il ne fait que
reculer finalement les solutions on les
connaît tous aujourd'hui les chefs
d'entreprise iban et l'économie le
peuple qu'on voit devant nous
aujourd'hui connais des solutions mais
c'est impossible de faire les solutions
avec ceux qui ont causé cette chute
c'est impossible d'avoir des solutions
avec ceux qui ont décapité des fonds
publics qui ont des la bid et les fonds
publics qui venaient de l'extérieur
finalement nous savons très bien que
pour s'en sortir il faut un changement
dramatique un changement de toute la pop
les deux de tout là de toute l'arène
politique je dirais pour pouvoir s'en
sortir
l'élection présidentielle sous haute
tension en guinée demain malgré des mois
de protestations populaires
le président alpha condé brigue un
troisième mandat à la tête du pays
les deux principaux challengers sont
donc comme depuis d'ailleurs une
décennie le leader de l'union des forces
démocratiques de guinée de cellou dallen
diallo et le champion du parti au
pouvoir le rassemblement du peuple de
guinée a représenté par le président
alpha condé qui est donc candidat à sa
propre succession à vie et une
opposition elle qui se dit
confronté aux menaces et aux
intimidations aux violences et aux
blocages de toutes sortes orchestrée par
le pouvoir écouter le président sortant
sait qui parle de lui
tiens ben ali
le président bon tir
aurait-elle de la pomme
terminé
avec
le thème
et voyez ce qu'en dit mouctar diallo il
est président du parti nouvelles forces
démocratiques également ministre de la
jeunesse et de l'emploi des jeunes de la
république de guinée soutient donc du
président sortant est pour lui l issue
du scrutin ne fait aucun doute écouté je
pense que vous avez eu l'occasion de
suivre le déroulement de la campagne
tu vas au moins je pense que les
observateurs ont bien vu la popularité
la forte adhésion des populations à la
cause ou à la candidature du candidat du
candidat du professeur alpha condé du
point que globalement on peut dire que
les choses sont en train de se mettre en
place ou que les élections plus avoir
lieu
qui ment de façon apaisée commission de
transport l'actualité internationale en
bref et en images à présent un nouveau
record de levée de fonds pour joe biden
le candidat démocrate à la maison
blanche a battu en septembre dernier son
propre record mensuel il a réussi à
récolter 383 millions de dollars au mois
d'août dernier il avait déjà réussi à
dépasser le montant rassemblés par
barack obama
un afflux de dons qui a été observé
après son premier duel télévisé contre
donald trump
100e jour de protestation en bulgarie
manifestation hier soir de plusieurs
milliers de personnes à sofia la
capitale une contestation contre le
gouvernement et l'élite politique
considéré comme corrompu par ses
militants la bulgarie est l'état le plus
pauvre de l'union européenne
et puis en nouvelle zélande la victoire
du parti travailliste de la première
ministre et ja sinda à terme selon les
premiers résultats
à tout juste 40 ans la cheffe du
gouvernement néo zélandais pourrait
obtenir la majorité absolue ce qui
serait une première depuis 24 ans à
wellington
le principal parti d'opposition de
centre-droit a déjà reconnu sa défaite
aller retour en france pour terminer
cette édition avec ses épargnes et des
restrictions liées à la crise sanitaire
il s'agit du festival lumière à lyon qui
se tient jusqu'à demain
l'occasion pour certains manifestants de
faire entendre leur voix pour venir en
aide aux personnes précaires nicolas
petit c'est un cri du coeur un appel à
l'aide
marié l'une des porte-parole de quatre
associations et collectifs du rhône qui
ont décidé de s'exprimer vendredi sur la
scène du festival lumière leur volonté
alerter sur la situation des personnes
précaires depuis l'émergence du coc vide
on avait envie de parler des précaires
des intermittents de l'emploi qui
aujourd'hui sont pas du tout pris en
compte par le gouvernement alors que ils
sont dans une situation catastrophique
et
et on sait avec les frères dardenne
venait à lyon et tout leur cinéma parle
de ces populations-là de ces gens qui
sont précaires du coup ça nous semblait
intéressant de faire le lien entre ce
cinéma que beaucoup de gens adorent et
le fait qu'il ya des gens qui sont
vraiment comme ça dans la vraie vie et
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont besoin de notre
soutien pouvoir profiter de la présence
des frères dardenne réalisateur
mondialement connu et porteurs de
messages forts
une occasion que ses porte paroles ne
voulait pas manquer depuis le mois de
mars dans le rhône des milliers
d'intérimaires et de salariés se
retrouvent sans emploi est complètement
démuni depuis le confinement notre
chômage et des comptes et nous n'avons
pas le droit au chômage partiel
notre nos jours
de rémunération sont des fentes et donc
maintenant nous sommes à plus de
150 jours des comtés et ne pourront pas
renouveler nos droits correctement au
sein de au sein du pôle emploi parce que
nous ne pouvons pas effectuer nos heures
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui le 16 mars 2020
lors du discours annonçant l'entrée en
confinement
emmanuel macron avait déclaré qu'aucune
française aucun français ne serait
laissé sans ressources
pourtant les précaires déplore toujours
l'absence de mesures d'urgence en leur
faveur
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes rester rythme
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]